well ladies and gentlemen Carrie Lake
said she would win she said there was no
way she would lose unless it was stolen
or rigged or fraudulent she insisted
even hours uh into yesterday's final
counting in Arizona that she would
ultimately Prevail and become the next
governor of Arizona
and Carrie lake has lost it is good news
for sensible people and sane people not
only in Arizona not only in the United
States but it is good news for the world
we have a world as Donald Trump famously
said and that world is rejoicing other
than some clowns in Arizona
because Kerry Lake will not be the next
governor of that state instead it will
be Katie Hobbs the Democrat a completely
uncontroversial unremarkable just normal
Democrat who will hopefully run Arizona
in something approximating a logical way
she won't say well we're going to secede
she won't say end covid lockdowns and
mandates that don't exist she won't try
to ban abortion and on and on and on it
has been a very slow count in Arizona
but it was finally called yesterday
Katie Hobbs prevailing over Kerry Lake
Carrie Lake adding yet another major
endorsement fracchus to Donald Trump's
list
and
um Carrie Lake and many others insisting
that it is indeed fraud we will look at
Kerry Lake's reaction in a moment at the
current time it is a nearly 20 000 vote
margin for Katie Hobbs
um under one point understand but uh it
has been called and it is fortunately
very much over what makes this all the
sweeter and I admit I take pleasure in
this what makes this all the sweeter is
the degree of arrogant confidence that
Kerry Lake exhibited up until quite
literally hours before this was called
The Arrogant confidence of Donald Trump
insisting that Kerry Lake would win but
it started to Flip Flip Flip and get to
the point where well based on the
remaining votes Carrie Lake needs 53
percent now of the remaining votes
Carrie Lake needs 56 percent we knew
days ago that mathematically it really
just wasn't adding up for Kerry Lake and
indeed we have made it now what about
Carrie Lake's Twitter feed well it's
been relatively quiet she has a pinned
message from September and then only one
tweet that seems to be related to the
call
which is Arizona's no BS when they see
it arizonans know BS when they see it
and of course I had to get in there uh
and respond to her and tell her indeed
arizonans SOB the BS of your campaign
and they voted for your opponent
um a a repetitive
screeds and tirades from Kerry Lake
shouldn't election officials be
impartial the guys running the election
have made it their mission to defeat
America First Republicans and then if
there was an issue with your ballot
please submit the information here
attention your vote may not have been
counted you can check the status at
kerrylake.com cure this is a whole thing
where they want to cure the ballots and
as all of you know
why cure with so much salt when you can
cold smoke and get all the flavor in a
much less salty ballot I prefer cold
smoking rather than curing but that's a
culinary question for later
um Carrie like continuing you know your
vote may not have been counted and on
and on and on she has not conceited as
of this point in time I could not care
less whether or not she concedes as many
of you know concession is merely a
formality it is something that you know
reasonable people do even lunatic Doug
mastriano
called Josh Shapiro and said sir I
concede I concede sir you have won this
election
um something Donald Trump never really
did after 2020
and Carrie Lake may not do it either but
a victory for common sense in Arizona
let's continue talking about this a
little bit more uh you guys remember
massive dumps no no I'm not talking
about those of you who have little
babies at home I'm talking about this
phrase that Donald Trump started using
to Signal fraud in 2020 that there were
dumps of ballots seemingly without even
a hint of understanding the Absurd and
ironic nature of that phrase just
moments before the Arizona gubernatorial
race was called against Kerry lake lake
appeared on Fox news with Jesse Waters
and again without like a shred of
self-awareness of how stupid they sound
talking about these dumps
they started talking about dumps listen
to this
what's gonna happen when we hear about
this vote dump in about I don't know
minutes it could be Carrie I I don't
know we know we think we should be in
good shape yeah we think it's going to
be a pretty favorable dump
The Hunt County where they took our
sacred vote and they and they just made
a mockery of it they dumped all over the
boat rage is Jesse what happened I had a
man come up to me at breakfast yesterday
he had tears in his eyes no sir said I
showed up to vote there was a three-hour
line they said the tabulator machines
were not working I drove across the way
and went to another 15-minute drive to
another Center and the printing uh
printers weren't working they had no
toner in them I drove another 20 minutes
and finally voted it was a half a day
Odyssey to cast my vote and we're
getting thousands of people reaching out
saying the exact same thing we don't
know how many people just finally gave
up because it was so hard to vote and
when they did get to the front of the
line only to find out the tabulator
wasn't going to count their vote it was
all right so anyway she's going on about
things going Beyond just dumps at this
point in time remember that every one of
the claims that she made was either
refuted or explained there was an issue
with the tabulator the only person that
was going around saying leave this
polling place and go to a different one
to have your vote counted were
Republicans in support of Kerry Lake
that was a self-inflicted blunder the
election officials from Maricopa County
who by the way are Republicans came out
and said listen there was an issue with
a with a tabulator we fixed the issue
everything's fine and of course they are
relying on Old tropes in this case the
infamous massive dumps quote just
because you hear dumps doesn't mean
anything was stolen but remember this
iconic moment from failed former
president Donald Trump and what happened
if you watched the election I was called
by the biggest people uh saying
congratulations political people
congratulations sir you just won the
election it was 10 o'clock and you
looked at the numbers and I'm sure you
felt that way right this election was
over and then they did dumps they call
them dumps big massive dumps in Michigan
and Pennsylvania yeah and the Maria
Bartiromo moment where she adjusts her
glasses As Trump repeats that there were
dumb is really just uh it's I believe
it's one of the most important moments
in political media History of the United
States all right so they went the route
of the dumps and the dumps were not in
their favor and Carrie Lake lost last
thing I want to touch on with Kerry Lake
just the hilarity of the final people
insisting that she would win even though
it was clear she didn't have the numbers
Carrie Lake herself and other extremists
insisted she was going to win until the
very last moment at a certain point you
have to ask do they not understand basic
math do they not understand the degree
to which they need to overwhelm the
remaining ballots the further they fall
behind and don't they realize wow
I haven't gotten 60 of the vote anywhere
so far I need 60 of everything that's
left to win it's probably over for me
they don't seem to get it or they don't
care let's go through this here is
Carrie Lake up until the last moment
look at how confidently she insisted I'm
gonna win I'm gonna win do you find it
somewhat problematic at all that your
opponent Katie Hobbs is Secretary of
State and she didn't recuse herself by
the way this happened in Georgia
previously where the secretary of state
was running for governor they they none
of these Republicans had any problem
with it now they have a problem with it
I'm overseeing this election an election
that she's actually very much running in
yes I did as a matter of fact right
after I got into the race I've done
threw my hat into the ring in June of
21. that next month in July I recognize
that would be a problem and we put out a
very hard push for her to recuse herself
from any aspects of her job as Secretary
of State that oversaw any part of the
elections as she refused to do so and we
saw how botched the August 2nd Primary
election was much of that can be
attributed to her incompetence and now
we're seeing all the problems with this
election and I think it's just going to
when I win it's going to be a sigh of
relief yeah well that was uh that was
yesterday and indeed the sigh of relief
was that Kerry Lake lost here's Marjorie
Taylor green talking about that critical
Arizona race just yesterday we lost in
2020 because of that because of the
mail-in ballots and because it was ripe
for election fraud and now we're
watching it again especially in Carrie
likes race over in Arizona this this
shouldn't be this way everyone was
calling for a red wave either all the
pollsters were wrong and they need to be
fired and that's Republican Democrat I
mean that's what they've been saying
forever these Republicans forever have
been saying fire the pollsters the media
pollster saying that we were going to
get a red wave or we have to finally
acknowledge the factory at least we have
to get the other side to acknowledge the
fact and admit the truth that mail-in
ballots is the biggest problem in our
elections mail-in ballots are the
biggest problem in our election so
Marjorie Taylor green jumping Full Speed
Ahead into the fraud element and she
says listen all these right-wing
pollsters told us there was going to be
a red wave now there wasn't it must have
been fraud it must have been fraud and
then here is January 6th Riot organizer
Ali Alexander saying that he's going to
will carry Lake to win this was just
yesterday morning hours later she lost
even if Carrie was going to lose I would
will it into existence
and I know that sounds kooky yes and I
know that sounds crazy yes
but
just don't catch me on a wild day
Pete Davidson one time got on my bad
side
yeah and almost killed himself
so what
you're not gonna believe me it doesn't
matter
the point is is that no one needs to
believe you the first time the point is
you just need to tell them the first
time okay do you understand this no this
is gonna sound kooky for y'all and cozy
but you guys don't understand the
esoteric oh
what if I told you
that
all of us are capable of traveling well
not all of us because you're not smart
enough but what if I told you that there
are a lot of people capable of time
traveling they just don't know it what
if I told you that time traveling
is easier than you think yep well uh
this is exactly the caliber of person
that was supporting Carrie lake so you
know whether it's because it was willed
or prayed for or someone traveled
forward in time or back in time Carrie
lake has lost and we can all rejoice it
is a bullet dodged
huge work to be done over the next two
years make sure you're subscribed to the
YouTube channel a lot of people 3.2
million last month watched our videos
didn't subscribe to the YouTube channel
make sure you hit that subscribe button
help us get to 2 million and we will
take a very quick break and be back
after this
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
all right give you a quick update on the
Herschel Walker uh Rafael Warnock runoff
December 6th of course in Georgia this
will determine not who controls the
Senate Democrats have taken control of
the Senate it is currently 50 to 49 but
that race that runoff will determine is
it a 50-50 senate for two years where
Kamala Harris is the tie-breaking vote
for Democrats or will Democrats have a
51-49 majority which at least takes care
of Joe manchin or Kirsten Cinema without
requiring Kamala Harris's tie-breaking
vote Herschel Walker continues to speak
and it becomes increasingly clear every
time he does
that he doesn't have any idea what is
going on Herschel Walker held it's it's
truly Beyond parody at this point in
time Walker her walker held an event in
which he I think he's trying to attack
Raphael Warnock here
but he really is criticizing himself
you'll see what I mean in a moment here
in this first clip Herschel Walker
addressing the issue of keeping one's
own kids keeping one's own kids and did
he even paid himself a child care all
that stuff why don't he keep his own
kids don't have nobody to keep your kid
you keep your kids he's got somebody
that's killing me I keep my own even
though he lied about me it's okay it's
okay because he's trying to get your
vote don't let him trick you try to get
your vote
what is Herschel Walker talking about
right there
is Herschel Walker saying that Raphael
Warnock should parent his children
because one of the things we learned
about Herschel Walker is that he's been
an absent father to multiple kids or am
I make trying to make more sense of it
than we can make listen to this again
what is he talking about and then he
even paid himself a child care all that
stuff why don't he keep his own kids
don't have nobody to keep your kid you
keep your kids he got somebody that's
keeping I keep my own even though he
lied about me it's okay it's okay
because he's trying to get your vote
don't let a trick you try to get your
vote how can you hear that and think
that's someone who should be making
decisions about what our tax rates
should be
that's somebody who I would want to be
one of 100 votes for the entire country
as to decisions on foreign policy it
just doesn't make any sense literally it
doesn't make any sense here's one more
clip at another event where Herschel
Walker yesterday is I mean I guess I
don't even know how to report on this I
guess he's trying to make the case that
he would be a good Senator fundamentally
that's what this is about and he
attacked the green agenda and said that
we should continue having gas guzzling
cars and it's not clear whether he
doesn't understand gas guzzling is a
pejorative or whether he likes it you
know some of these people love the idea
of damaging the environment they sort of
take pride in it they say it's manly and
patriotic listen to this and again
try to make heads or tails out of it I
promise you
[Music]
Jenna I raised my hand right now but
we're not ready right now so don't let
them fool you like this is a new agenda
this is not a new agenda we're not
prepared we're not ready right now what
we need to do is keep damn those gas
guzzling cars so we got the good
emission under those cars we're doing
the best thing that we can but we need
help we need help and those other people
not helping us China's not helping us in
here not helping us but yeah we're gonna
do it all because they spending your
money
doesn't make any sense I know that most
of those words are English but it
doesn't make any sense and the hope is
if Herschel Walker's lack of
qualifications are made clear if
Herschel Walker's hypocrisy on so many
issues is made clear
and if we do the door knocking and we do
the phone Banking and to the extent that
you do need to raise money in order to
win a senate seat people donate to
Rafael Warnock hopefully this goes in
warnock's favor I continue to say it
would be such a massive humiliation to
the country to the country to see
Herschel Walker be a senator
that we really need to pull out all the
stops and prevent it from happening and
by the way we're going to be up against
Kelly Lefler you tell me whether that's
scary or not Kelly Lefler the Republican
senator who lost to Rafael Warnock in
Georgia in 2021 says her organization is
going to be helping out Herschel Walker
I don't know if that's a promise or a
threat from Kelly Lefler based on how
things went she appeared on Fox Business
and she said we're going to help
Herschel we're going to help Herschel
check this out throw that Governor Kemp
has thrown his support behind Herschel
really from day one and now he's
throwing his ground game behind it as
are we and the key here is that we want
everyone to come in and support this
effort but this effort is about
Georgians and I'm calling on Georgians
to get involved to support Herschel yeah
so Kelly Lefler she's got a lot of money
Kelly Lefler and her husband reportedly
are worth about 800 million dollars
there's no doubt she has money to
contribute to this effort we have to
hope that it's yet another failure and
that the outcome is exactly the same as
the outcome from 2021 remember in 2021
this was because of the 50 rule in
Georgia both Georgia Senate seats in
2021 in 2020 rather went to special
elections which took place on January
5th 2021 we covered them you may
remember John ossoff Won and Raphael
Warnock won Warnock is the one who faced
off against Kelly Lefler Warnock won by
two percent of the vote
um it was just under a 100 000 vote
margin so the hope is the Hope is that
again some Republicans won't vote
because they feel it's rigged listen I'm
not going to go out there and try to
suppress the vote it's not my move but
if they want to tell themselves on each
other don't bother voting because it's
rigged and your vote won't vote won't
matter by all means tell each other that
that's absolutely fine and if indeed the
same failed ground game that lost Kelly
lefler's election in 2020 2021 is going
to be in play here I say absolutely
fantastic thing let's let them do it now
that being said
you know no matter what position I take
a portion of the audience is mad and
this is this happens with just about
every election what's my real feeling
about this Georgia runoff
my real feeling is it's probably like
a 55 ish percent chance Warnock wins 55
maybe 60 chance based on the totality of
everything that's going on and how
previous special elections have gone
just all these different things
no matter what numbers I assess or no
matter what polling I look at it's
always the same thing with the audience
and I think we could much more
productively deal with this I'm not a
news show I'm a commentary show so when
you take a race like this if I say to
you listen
um the polls are basically split 50 50
but based on you know everything from
more Republicans died of covet than
Democrats so it killed more Republican
voters to special elections in Georgia
recently have been good for the
Democratic candidate combined with
there's maybe some right-wing polls that
are averaged in that are not too trust
okay some people will write to me and
say David
you are dissuading democratic voters
from voting were you when you say I
think it's probably a 55 or 60 chance
that Warnock wins voters in Georgia will
hear that Democratic voters and they're
going to stay home it's very dangerous
what you're doing
okay
if I understate the degree of support I
get emails from people who say David and
I got these when I was just looking at
polling with caveats leading up to last
week's midterm people would email me and
say David
why are you buying into this right-wing
narrative that Republicans are going to
do well it's all push-poling in Georgia
these are trash right-wing polls and if
voters Democratic voters hear you say
Walkers leading they're going to stay
home
first of all it's a sort of you're
damned if you do damned if you don't
situation I'm not creating the polls and
I'm not doing news reporting I'm
synthesizing what's out there and giving
you my opinion which is I think the
circumstances slightly favor Warnock I
don't know whether the polling we have
between now and December 6 which is so
soon will really be trustworthy it could
go either way everyone should vote
that's that's the reality
any position
can be used to claim that I'm doing the
wrong thing and by the way
any position could also be used to say
well that means we really should vote
right if the truth is oh this is 50 50
and it's leaning red that's not a reason
for Democrats to stay home that's a
reason for Democrats to get out to vote
so let's allow ourselves to recognize
simultaneously
we only have certain numbers of things
we can look at to figure out what is
going on and it's okay to look at those
things and also at the end of the day
cheering and booing doesn't count for
who wins and polling doesn't count for
who wins voting counts for who wins
let's allow ourselves to understand
those things all right make sure you're
following us on Instagram at
davidpackman show what's Happening by
the way with the big announcement
tonight we'll talk about that next
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show it's great
to be joined today by Nick Lane who's
professor of evolutionary biochemistry
at University College London also the
author of Five Books some of which I've
read including Transformer the Deep
chemistry of life and death really
appreciate you being on today thank you
well thank you for the invitation
pleasure to be here so I think maybe to
kind of frame the conversation
certain areas of science are studied in
particular Ways by biology for example
has increasingly looked at genetic
information as one particular way that
we study it the origins of Life
intelligent life Consciousness whatever
this the approach to that study has been
a particular way over the last several
decades do you think generally speaking
that in these fields science is focusing
on the right questions and the right
approaches or is there sort of like a
paradigm shift that you think would be
more useful in answering some of the key
questions we don't yet have answers to
uh well I do think a paradigm shift
would be useful that's not to say
everything that people have been
studying is wrong
um you know it's it's taken us a long
way down the path but the the danger is
that if you think it's only about genes
and information and so on then you kind
of miss the broader Point there's more
to life than just genetic information uh
it's it's kind of a statement to the
obvious uh but but it's amazing how kind
of how much tunnel vision you can have
in research that people know effectively
where the funding is going to come from
the kind of things that will attract
funding the kind of things that you can
do a lot of science is about what you
can physically go and do in the lab what
uh what you know what technical
equipment do you have to go and explore
this question and then I have to say
science is intrinsically quite
conservative
um and any ideas that seem to be too far
outside the box uh tend to be squashed
uh you know and there's lots of ideas
outside the box and probably a fairly
High proportion of them probably
including some of my own uh ought to be
squashed but you you know you don't
squash them without thinking about it
you squash them after uh after you know
testing them trying it a little bit just
see see where it takes you well that's
very interesting because there are some
uh in the you know science communication
Community I guess we would call it for
lack of a better term who often repeat
and like to say that one of the great
differences between science and religion
is that with an organized religion
dissenting views are often squashed or
dismissed you become a pariah of sorts
in contrast to the scientific World
we're actually being able to debunk or
disprove previously uh uh held beliefs
is greatly revered and celebrated and
welcomed and there's great celebrity
available to scientists if they are able
to do that is that only true in some
sense or in some cases
um there is a lot of Truth in that which
is to say I won't speak for the for the
religious side of it but for the
scientific side yes I think most
scientists most of the time set out to
try and do something new to try and you
know over time on the apple cart to some
extent but the whole system of peer
review the whole system of of kind of
double checking everything and making
sure that uh that this is bona fide that
this is solid research that you've not
missed something obvious that you've
you've got all the controls and all this
stuff well who does the peer review the
people who do the peer reviewer the
people who have in effect already
established their careers within
establishing the current Paradigm and so
as a group of people they are by Nature
I mean kind of almost by definition
relatively conservative and if you
really do come up with a completely new
paradigm then you really will overturn a
lot of people's work
um and so being revolutionary is not an
easy thing to do I'm not saying I'm
revolutionary I think I'm I'm just
talking plain common sense to be honest
with you but um but but this is this is
something that anybody who is genuinely
uh has transformative ideas in science
will come up against the
conservativeness of peer review and and
as I say probably nine out of 10 people
with what looked like mad ideas will
really have mad ideas that will turn out
not to be true and it's probably right
that they don't get too far but one out
of those ten maybe you know genuinely
brilliant to genius who who and they
face uh kind of problems with the social
construction of science yes
to talk a little more specifically about
one of your books Transformer the Deep
chemistry of life and death as we kind
of mentioned at the start of the
conversation there's been a lot of focus
on genetic information in the field of
biology and
um one of the areas that you explore
again to the extent that I I hopefully
understood it somewhat correctly in the
book is about metabolism and looking at
sort of the cellular level and when we
talk about life and death really looking
at what is it that is happening there
now we've talked to scientists who
specialize in human longevity for
example and they've explained in a way
that is relevant to that particular
field the idea of over time the body
losing the ability to replace cells of
different types A deterioration of sorts
that that takes place Etc that's
specific to the field of longevity and
the the language sort of serves that
that purpose can you talk a little bit
about the the angle that you take here
and really this process that's at the
core or that you describe
yeah what I'm really interested in is is
how energy works in biology because it's
not it's not as you might imagine it
it's actually electrical I suppose a lot
of people might immediately think it's
electrical if you think about
Frankenstein's monster or something you
have an electric shock and off they go
um and we are
all are inside ourselves we have these
things called mitochondria they're often
called the power packs of cells and they
have they have an electrical charge
across their membrane which is a you
know a trivial charge we're talking 150
200 millivolts but if you were to shrink
yourself down to the size of a molecule
um and kind of stand next to the
membrane the membrane is so thin it's
it's five millionths of a millimeter in
thickness five nanometers thick
um that the the actual strength of the
field that you would experience if you
were there is about 30 million volts per
meter which is equivalent to a bolted
lightning so this is what's keeping us
alive and and nobody imagined uh until
you know it's a few decades this is not
new information but a few decades ago it
came as really quite a shock to discover
that effectively life is powered by
electrical charges and electrical Fields
across membranes
um and so for me the interesting
question is why how did that get going
it's quite a complex system what
happened at the origin of life this is
conserved across all of life and also if
we look across this you know whole four
billion year history of life on Earth
it's pretty weird as well what we
actually see is the first two billion
years is just bacteria and really
nothing else and actually if you think
about it from the point of view of
bacteria they're still there they're
still just bacteria or nothing so we
have a four billion year history of life
on Earth which is just bacteria and then
at one point
um which is to say all the evidence
suggests at one point you you have the
emergence what looks like quite an
Abrupt emergence in geological terms of
our own type of cell what are they
called eukaryotic cells or that means a
cell with a nucleus and the nucleus is
where we put our DNA the the genes
um and and so we have the same cell type
that plants do and that you know
mushrooms fungi and so on do and and
large single cell Critters things like
amoeba they also have the same cell
structure now if you think if you think
about you know we know all we've got all
of these Gene sequences
from the history of life from bacteria
all around the world and what it tells
us is that the bacteria in another group
that look a lot like them called archaea
have basically explored the kind of Gene
sequence space that all the
possibilities that you could have across
all of evolution from exploring
different Gene sequences they've done
that much better than our type of cell
have them eukaryotic cells have and yet
somehow they got stuck in this rut they
they remain simple in their morphology
they're not simple in their genetics or
they're biochemistry but they're simple
in their size and their shapes and you
know the the kind of things going on
inside and so
it seemed I would say that that says
they're not limited by genetics they're
not limited by the searching of sequence
space they're limited by something else
and that's something I think is the
structure because what all eukaryotes
have in common is they in they they
swallowed a bacterium one billion years
ago which went on to become these power
packs of mitochondria with this powerful
electrical charge across all the
membranes so effectively they
internalized respiration in a
compartment
which which allowed them to scale up
become large and complex and and more or
less get beyond the constraints that
energy has so obviously cells need
energy but not many people have thought
about well how is it provided and and
and what we actually have is we have
genes in our mitochondria and genes in
our nucleus and you need both sets of
genes to control this electrical charge
and that's that's the kind of a shift in
cell structure which changed the whole
history of evolution and everything
that's possible and if we look for life
on other planets and you think are we
going to find the same kind of thing
that we're going to find people are we
going to find intelligent aliens
whatever it may be the likelihood is
we'll find bacteria for exactly the same
reasons that the Earth was dominated by
bacteria for most of its history when we
think forward based on this framework
you know I recently read the book
precipice by Toby ORD which looks at
some of the more uh I guess we would say
anthropogenic risks to humanity and he
sort of goes through uh nuclear war
climate change Etc and kind of frames
the conversation in from what we know
here's roughly how long species last
here's roughly what we think about
mammalian species and and take sort of
that approach to how long might Homo
sapiens last if we were to not destroy
ourselves but it's a very socially uh
informed kind of perspective when you
think about the future of homo sapiens
is that side the one that seems most
predictive or is what we're talking
about here quite literally how cells get
their energy and the waste of cells
which do you think as Humanity continues
to presumably Advance technologically
will bear a greater weight on what
eventually happens to humans
uh well I mean I I fear for the next
phase of human history I mean we are
very capable of screwing this up badly
um and and effectively eliminating
ourselves from the planet now we will
not under any circumstances eliminate
life from the planet I suppose a
full-scale nuclear Armageddon might just
do it but even then there will be plenty
of bacteria left I'm sure dig down in
the crust and so on and probably plenty
of eukaryotes down there as well so this
transition from just the bacteria to uh
to to to eukaryotic cells I don't think
we'd have to go through that again and
we've had you know major mass
extinctions in the past where where 70
80 90 percent of of species get wiped
out
um you move the clock forward by five
ten million years and and you have a
fully vibrant planet again so really
what we're in danger of doing is
destroying ourselves and everything we
care about and
and and and then the planet will
readjust and in 10 million years it'll
just be without us
um would we get back all the Majesty
that we see around us it's hard to say
it depends just how effective we are in
wiping everything else out so that's my
biggest fear because there are tipping
points and there is it's it's all very
well to say we should be optimistic we
can fix any problem we put our minds to
I would agree with that but we need the
political will we need the political
governance and management you know we're
also capable of scuppering the best laid
plans that Humanity can come up with and
it maybe we just leave it too late
beyond beyond some Tipping Point so
that's the biggest threat to humanity it
doesn't matter how long mammalian
species might normally last we can do
ourselves in within the next 20 years or
something we're in a special unique
situation now
we really are unique in the sense that I
don't think any other species Beyond
well not even a virus could take out the
entire planet in the way that we're
capable of doing so I don't know that
it's necessarily helpful to think in
general terms about the future I think
we need to fix very specific problems
now but if we're if we're thinking about
you know if we do go into those general
terms and think about well
uh can we for example solve lifespan so
that we live indefinitely
um I I think it will be difficult
what I mean there's two there's two
aspects in biology that says it's
possible one of them is that life itself
is effectively Immortal in the sense
that there is an unbroken chain of cells
that go right back to the origin of life
and those cells were metabolically
active all the way through
um so so there's no necessity that
damage accumulates and and overcomes
everything and then there are some you
know things like flatworms and so on
there's a few fairly simple animals that
uh are in effect Immortal and can live
indefinitely but they're usually pretty
simple
and the things that we most care about
are
you know our minds and our minds are
incredibly delicate structures made up
of synapse you know trillions of
synaptic connections
um and and
to preserve those is is a is a very
difficult thing to do and the the
decision Evolution has made historically
if you like is um
how much effort do I want to put into
the preservation of the organism
compared to the replication of the
organism and and the decision for humans
is well you know 70 80 90 years
um that allows you time to have a few
kids and and look after them and even
the grandparents can help look after
them whatever it may be this is a kind
of an evolutionary bargain if you like
and the bargain says you have a limited
lifespan because this is all we're going
to invest in your own prolongation as an
organism so we need to know the kind of
the details of the small print that says
here's why you here's why your life is
coming to an end and see if we can fix
that
um a lot of people wouldn't want to fix
that uh I think it would be quite
difficult in any case to do it
um so it's not it's not if you like a
threat in the immediate future I don't
think though you could talk to other
people who think that we already have
people on this planet who are going to
live to a thousand or something
short of that and I've interviewed some
of those people yeah Aubry de gray has
been saying for 20 years I think that
the first person to live to a thousand
has lived in the limited time we have
left it's almost cliche because it's so
repeated now and sometimes things get
repeated and do we do they really make
sense but there's this idea that
the best we can hope to do with
standard human bodies is about 120 or
125 years
yeah and so so that generally makes
sense to you that until we really start
making modifications that make us not
quite human that's going to be a very
difficult upper limit to get to get
Beyond
I I think it will be very difficult yes
I'm not saying it's not possible
um but uh but but it will be it will be
difficult yes and I think it'll take us
a while longer yeah I don't think we
understand biology nearly well enough
yet to get beyond that limit personally
right we've been speaking with Nick Lane
professor of evolutionary biochemistry
at University College London will link
to a number of his books including
Transformer the Deep chemistry of life
and death I really appreciate your time
today
thank you it was a pleasure
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
Trump 2024 may be dying before it even
starts in multiple new 2024 Republican
polls Ron DeSantis is leading Donald
Trump and this is before Trump makes his
big announcement tonight which we will
talk about in a moment there are two
arguments about the importance of this
which we will talk about in a moment
first and foremost there is a you gov
America poll and it asked Republicans do
you prefer DeSantis or Trump in 2024
Republicans and Republican leaners say
42 percent Ron DeSantis 35 Donald Trump
10 neither 13 not sure now the neither
and the not sure could make the
difference and push it back to Trump but
we are now for the first time getting
these types of numbers this poll was
conducted November 9 to 11 meaning it
was after the 2022 midterm and indeed it
would be a logical causation to infer
although for now we can say it's a
correlation it could be a causation that
Trump's controversial and sort of like
contested
endorsements in 2022 that went bad
that includes Kerry Lake although we
didn't know about that until yesterday
um mehmed Oz Doug mastriano Etc that the
failure of those endorsements has
reinvigorated support for someone other
than Trump now you might say well David
Sir with total respect and tears in my
eyes that's only one poll well there are
now multiple polls that show DeSantis
leading yes there's a new morning
consult poll in which Trump is still
winning
however we now have a CWS research poll
in Texas which shows Texas prefers
DeSantis over Trump 43-32 that's a
pretty big deal we have a Georgia
Republican primary poll from WPA
intelligence which shows DeSantis plus
20 over Trump we have one in Florida
which shows DeSantis plus 26 over Trump
New Hampshire DeSantis plus 15. Iowa
DeSantis plus 11 and one from the
association for Canadian studies for a
general National primary which shows
DeSantis plus two
this splits this changed right after
November 8th now there's two arguments
here argument one is that this is all
completely irrelevant okay the argument
that it's irrelevant is
if you actually have Trump and DeSantis
running an ugly contested
snippy primary against each other Trump
will do the same sort of stuff that he
did in 2016 making fun of people
ridiculing them being Teflon and that
ultimately DeSantis isn't going to be
able to do it and that DeSantis is going
to fall off
there are some major differences however
number one
if indeed this is a two candidate race
Trump versus DeSantis that's very
different than what would have happened
then what did happen in 2015 and 2016
which was you had 18 candidates or 19
candidates to start with you had a lot
of these ones and twos people pulling
one and two percent and Trump just would
stick it out long enough for one of the
ones and twos to fall off and Trump
picks up a point
and then another one of the ones and
twos falls off and Trump picks up
another point or two there was this
attrition sort of dynamic
if you just start with really just two
candidates in 2024 Trump and DeSantis
with Trump being a known political
entity with Trump already being
president with Trump already losing
himself in 2020 and hurting Republicans
in 22 you can argue the circumstances
are so different
that it is not going to be a similar
situation but for the first time the
betting Market's now pointing to
DeSantis over Trump in the primary and
increasingly polling pointing to
DeSantis over Trump tonight is the big
announcement Donald Trump at 9 00 PM
Eastern tonight will be making an
announcement the expectation is that
he's going to announce he's running for
president although there are many people
telling him don't do it at least don't
do it yet Donald Trump in his infinite
delusions of grandeur is saying that
hopefully this announcement will be one
of the most important days in American
history think about that Donald Trump
believes that whatever he's going to say
tonight
and we will carry it live
is going to be one of the most important
days in the history of the United States
talk about narcissism Donald Trump
posting yesterday on his platform truth
social truth essential quote hopefully
tomorrow will turn out to be one of the
most important days in the history of
our Capital C country and then again
today Trump posting hopefully today will
turn out to be one of the most important
days in the history of our country
however not everybody thinks this is a
good idea Donald Trump's final former
press secretary Kaylee mcenany
says Trump should not declare today take
a listen to this and that could go
straight through the state of Georgia
does that include Trump I think he needs
to put it on pause absolutely look he'll
make that decision
but does he go to I'm advising any
Contender DeSantis Trump whomever no one
announces 2024 until we get through
December 6th do you see the former
president I need for him to go to
Georgia I I think we've got to make
strategic calculations um Governor
DeSantis I think he should be welcome to
the state given what happened last night
if you've got to look you got to look at
the reality is on the ground and
Herschel Walker we've got to win the
Senate that's it guys got to win the
Senate all right we'll move on uh the
Democrats first yeah so Kaylee doesn't
think this is such a good idea at least
not before the December 6th uh runoff
now some have speculated that Trump is
going to change his plan tonight and
instead will announce something about
Herschel Walker however he's already
scamming people out of money claiming
it'll go to Herschel Walker it'll go
mostly to him I'll get to that in a
moment another person who doesn't think
Trump should be announcing tonight is uh
Republican Governor uh John sununu take
a listen to this I know you say the
media loves to talk about Donald Trump
and perhaps that's fair but it's not
just the media it's Donald Trump himself
and he's planning to announce for
president sorry guys it's Chris sununu I
I apologize Chris sununu is that a good
idea
uh for him no I think it's a terrible
idea for him I was look from just a
purely political standpoint uh we we
still don't know what's going to happen
in Georgia the votes are still being
counted in Nevada and and and Arizona by
the way no no not in Arizona yeah
is still undecided yeah only about 80 80
or 90 and so we'll see where that goes
but look people want to move away from
Politics as you hit Thanksgiving as you
hit Christmas as we're spending time
with families as we're trying to figure
out how we're going to fill our oil
tanks with all these high fuel prices so
now's just a horrible time for big
political uh statements uh you save that
for early 23 would be be my message but
either way it doesn't really matter it's
it's going to be great for the media
Saturday Night Live we'll probably love
it uh but for the rest of us we're going
to focus on spending time with our
families all right so Chris sununu does
not think Trump should announce his run
for presidency tonight and here's Jason
Miller one of Donald Trump's for a while
closest advisors he appeared on Newsmax
and he also said I wouldn't make this
announcement on November 15th today now
you just said everything over the next
month is about Herschel Walker having
said that I understood there could have
could be an announcement uh before that
uh from somebody that resides at Marvel
logo so does that change his plans as
far as announcing
so no formal decision yet of course
president Trump had said that he would
be making an announcement on November 15
next Tuesday I'm advising the president
to hold off until after the Georgia race
after Herschel Walker priorities a b and
c need to be about Herschel right now
this is bigger than anything else in the
country we got to show the focus is on
Georgia Keep the Country rallying in a
really critical point here is that Brian
Kemp holds many of the cards for what's
going to happen with Herschel Walker
there were a lot of the Kemp Warnock
ticket Splitters Kemp didn't do anything
for Herschel Walker in the general
election if Kemp wants to show that he's
a leader with some brighter future ahead
of him then he needs to get out there
and really hustle for a Herschel Walker
we need all hands right so the point
here is Jason Miller is advising Trump
not to do it but there is one person who
thinks it would be a great idea it
happens to be Donald Trump's
daughter-in-law Lara Trump when asked
given the poor results in the midterms
should Donald Trump really be announcing
and said absolutely I don't think
there's ever been a better time to be
honest with you for Donald Trump to come
back everywhere I go and I live in
obviously a very Republican state in the
State of Florida all I hear from people
is we need Donald Trump back we want him
back please tell us he's running
um so I don't think you can believe all
the headlines yep in her weird Echo
chamber bubble where she lives Lara
Trump thinks there is no better time
than right now for Donald Trump to
announce we will carry the event I'm not
even calling it the announcement anymore
the event tonight including reaction we
will be going live at 8pm Eastern the
announcements at 9 pm Eastern join me on
YouTube twitch and Facebook and remember
if you're not subscribed on YouTube you
really should be youtube.com the David
Pacman show Donald Trump has been caught
brutally scamming his own followers
again with a Herschel Walker fundraising
email where everything is meant to look
like the money is for Herschel Walker
but by default only 10 percent of the
donation actually goes to Herschel
Walker you have to see this Trump is a
known scammer Trump scams his followers
all the time what Trump's cares about is
what can you do for me now what money
can you give me now Walker's campaign
reports NBC News tells Republicans to
stop deceptive fundraising in the
Georgia runoff at least four committees
one of them associated with Trump have
kept 90 percent of contributions
solicited for Herschel Walker I will
explain to you how this works
uh and NBC also explains it
um The Campaign noticed the problem
Saturday
when former president Donald Trump save
America sent out an email that asked
prospective donors to quote contribute
any amount immediately to the official
Georgia runoff fundraising goal and
increase your impact by twelve hundred
percent
but if donors didn't see a link that
said click here for details or to edit
allocation they wouldn't have noticed 90
percent of the contributions
automatically go to the orange Menace
mango Mussolini Donald Trump and only 10
percent go to Walker
um this is uh we could actually look at
this this is a video put together by
Jacob rabashkin and what you will see as
you click through here is that you check
that you want to contribute a certain
amount and then there is this link in
this case it was 250 dollars that was
clicked there's a link that says click
here for details or to edit allocation
if you just click the 250 or whatever
amount and then you look at the
allocation you will see that oh in this
case it's a thousand dollars of the
thousand dollar contribution
900 was automatically allocated to go
wait a second to Donald Trump
but this was a Herschel Walker
fundraising email and yet unless you
modify it
only 10 of the donation goes to Herschel
Walker NBC news reports that after this
was highlighted
Trump's committee changed it to a 50-50
split a 50 50 split
this is
um not unique to Herschel Walker NBC
news reports that at least originally in
some JD Vance fundraising emails and Ted
Bud fundraising emails it was initially
also 90 10. subsequently some of those
were changed it's the final grift or
maybe not the real final grift may be
running for president again we just
don't know we'll find out tonight or
maybe we won't find out tonight but this
is what Donald Trump does and as I've
told you before
Trump doesn't like his followers Trump
doesn't respect his followers we all
know when we think about it Donald Trump
was a rich kid from New York City who
spent his life insulating and isolating
himself from the very people who now are
his supporters
sure to some degree he probably sees
them favorably to the extent that they
support him but we've seen very quickly
when there isn't anything for them to
vote for you for or for them to donate
to you for you flush them 10 or 15 times
Trump cares about his supporters if they
might vote for him for something or if
they might donate money and he is now
bilking them even more Trump's plane has
been repainted and refreshed and uh
renovated and fixed up so that now it is
flying him to rallies once again
uh these people who support him should
say wait a second we donated all this
money he became president he didn't do
any of the stuff he said he was going to
do didn't do the health care plan I
still have no health care I have
terrible Health Care he didn't build the
wall he didn't fix trade he didn't do
any of those things then he asked me for
more money
he lost in 2020. then he asked me for
more money and now he shows up making
terrible endorsements for people that
end up losing in 2022 and shows up in a
new plane did I pay for that plane have
I been scammed Again by this guy but
that is not the way they think it
through that does not seem to occur to
them uh and we will find out very very
soon
whether he still has the political
cachet to continue fundraising into
2023. we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today the Senate will act this week
to codify same-sex marriage federally
they say they have the votes do they I
think they do we'll talk about what this
will mean Google is paying nearly 392
million dollars to settle a huge
location tracking case
I have some personal experience with
this which I will share on today's bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad and
lastly even though Kevin McCarthy wants
to be the next speaker of the house if
Republicans indeed take control of the
House of Representatives
some Republicans are warning McCarthy
you don't have the votes to be the
Speaker of the House does he or doesn't
he and if not could he get them all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show sign up at joinpakman.com use the
coupon code 24 starts now to get a
beautiful discount I'll see you then